[Music]
hello everyone I am James Malone and I'm
joined here today by Karthik who's going
to come on stage in a few minutes run
through a demo and today we're going to
talk about cloud sparking the dupe
specifically on Google cloud data
Brockie the session today is going to
mix a few things first for anyone who
hasn't actually used data products or
doesn't know what data probably do or
why we've done it I'm just gonna set a
baseline and talk a little bit about
data proc some of the common design
patterns some of the common advice
specifically I'm gonna try and focus on
things we've told people in the past try
and help them go from on-premise or in
other clouds to cloud data proc I'm then
going to turn it over to Karthik who's
going to talk through some of our new
exciting features some of them we
haven't publicly announced yet so you
will actually be the first group to know
about some of these those features are
really designed to help make adopting
cloud data product faster and easier so
first I want to start off with looking
at just traditional SPARC and Hadoop
clusters a lot of spark native clusters
when people run them are monolithic so
they get a set of compute they get some
implementation of spark and a dupe they
slap it on the hardware they've
requested now hardware could be bare
metal it could be VMs it could be kind
of whatever often we see that those
clusters are off by themselves there may
be point integrations people run into
the challenges of trying to balance that
cluster so a configuration sort of a
butterfly flaps its wings over here it
causes trouble over here a small
configuration change you don't have to
think about how it might impact the old
cluster people have tenancy problems
either in terms of their security model
their resource utilization their
configuration it really ends up being a
bit of a frustrating mess the people are
just babysitting their cluster and
paying less time to actually getting
value out of sparking to do and to be
honest we see it turns a lot of people
into really frustrated users of sparking
to do which is unfortunate because they
end up kind of hating the
tools because there's so much just pain
involved in managing their clusters
which sucks like it shouldn't it
shouldn't be that way you should
actually like the open source you're
using not be beholden to it so this is
what I often refer to as the D value
chain of big data when people use open
source you get this hardware you then
have to configure it cloud has done a
good job of removing some of this pain
so instead of needing to rack servers
and configuring them you might just get
a VM and that's great but even then you
have some open source of implementation
or a proprietary implementation of
sparking to do P that needs to tune it
configure it it is a really really
frustrating experience for a lot of
people we see a lot of time spent in
people trying to manage their clusters a
lot of people that we run into think
they also need to do this because it
becomes a part of how they've operated
for so long so they've gotten used to
administrating their cluster and there's
a core set of tasks that they think they
have to do and when we try and peel that
away they don't and a lot of time that
they could have dedicated on writing
SPARC to go look at data or backfilling
old data to find new insights or
anything that's higher value than
sitting on their cluster they're not
doing because they're spending their
time on their clusters leads to a whole
bunch of pains so scaling even in a
cloud environment can be really tricky
and really painful utilization unless
you're running a femoral spark and a
dupe utilization is a bit of a moving
target so you're trying to plan out both
how much you think you need right now
which can actually just be tricky and
how much you think you might need in the
future
so unless you're using a firm well
sparking to do you're trying to match
how much you're spending with with how
much you're using and again you're
performing more accounting at that point
and sort of less engineering or less
technology we really think that the
cloud should make just focusing on your
data much easier so instead of focusing
on the cluster itself we want you to
focus on the technology so you don't
want to focus on you were sparking to do
cluster you want to focus on sparking
Hadoop and that's really why we went out
and design and continue to invest in
Cloud Data proc if you like using Apache
spark and you think there's awesome new
features and something like spark
two-three which
absolutely our we want you to focus on
those awesome new features and the value
they might bring to your data not how
you have to think about when you can
upgrade to spark two three on your
cluster or how you're gonna try and fit
it into your existing production
workflows so with plot data proc and if
anybody has seen past presentations this
is a familiar phrase and it's really a
phrase that sort of our mission
statement and it continues to underpin
our thinking in new features that we
developed for Claudia product we want
the spark in the dupe ecosystem and what
I say that that's the whole bucket of
components there's a lot that lives in
there there's a chase and tez and Impala
yeah so I often abbreviate it saying
sparking a drove ecosystem but it's
really not that whole big thing and some
of it is well most of its in the Apache
Software Foundation but a lot of it's
also related it could be things like
presto so just as a note when I say that
I sort of mean and I'm speaking to the
whole ecosystem that's where data brach
plays fast easy and cost-effective so
realistically we do want you to spend
less to do more sales people love me for
saying this but when you're using
sparkin to do you know save your money
for high-value stuff if you have a spark
job pay us for the compute resources and
for the management to go run that spark
job and then don't use the resources
when you don't have to use them for
something else hire more people to look
at your data or throw a party whatever
we don't really care we just don't want
you to waste your time your energy and
your sanity when you look at sort of
from fully D watt DIY to cloud data
proctors a few differences obviously
when we interact with a lot of customers
at the beginning of their journey
they're running their own managed
clusters sometimes in a cloud sometimes
on-premise and they're taking on the
full burden so they're managing their
Hardware the managing the software the
managing the configuration they may
bring in a vendor to help with the
Hadoop stack which is the middle column
so the vendor can help pre tune some of
the components they will create builds
for them they're often provide support
but there's still a lot that the
customer is responsible for managing
with pod at appraoch
not other things that's not to say we
want to abstract away your ability to do
things like custom to and spark or
inject new libraries or do really
advanced things data proc as a Google
cloud service stands out because it's
really knobby you'll find a lot of
Google cloud services are not knobby on
purpose data proc is a very knobby
service our philosophy is we want it to
be a knobby we want to preset those
knobs to the best of our ability and
you'll see some features that we're
working on today to add new knobs and
preset those for you but we want you to
be able to override to configure to
tweak but not have to think about it if
you don't want to because most of the
time you just don't have to think about
it under the hood data proc has a few
different layers I'm gonna be describing
this left to right just so people can
follow along everything that happens
with data proc generally happens through
the data proc a P I and that's not to
say that all interactions have to happen
through the cloud data property P I it's
just how many happen to to work so all
of our client tooling whether it's the
cloud console or the command light SDK
they're all talking to data bracha API
there's endpoints for clusters jobs
operations and now very recently
workflows where you can specify a
workflow that will allow you to create a
cluster execute a graph of jobs and
delete the cluster in one operation that
API will talk to data proctors
themselves which are built on top of
compute engine data proc clusters have n
number of master nodes depending on
whether you're running just standard
availability which is one or high
availability which is three those nodes
then run a Debian Jesse image with our
open source stack which we use Apache
Big Top to build on top of it you can
install additional components if you
want to likewise since data proc is
running on compute engine you can do
things like SSH into the VMS if you so
choose
we also inherit all of the power and
functionalities of compute engine so
networks GPUs the ability to create
clusters without public IP is attached
to them all of that is inherently part
of data products were built on compute
engine
you also see HDFS and HDFS is a bit of
an interesting odd duck here because
when you create a data proc cluster we
do provision HDFS the goal is that you
would only use that HDFS for temporary
operations so splittings billing
shuffling but you wouldn't store data on
HDFS persistently and the reason being
is we have a cloud storage connector
that's to do but who do compatible file
system compliant which allows you to use
cloud storage is an HDFS drop-in
replacement without having to run your
cluster 24/7 just to run HDFS so when a
lot of people move to cloudy to proc the
very first sort of big savings for them
is just not running a cluster all the
time to maintain their data over the
years there's been a set of common
pieces of advice we've given customers
try and help them get onto cloud data
proc as sort of painlessly and
effortlessly as possible
first separate storage and compute and
this goes to my Equipe about HDFS so to
the extent that you can separate your
data rest from your computation you'll
save obviously effort you'll save money
because you won't have to maintain the
compute needed just to store data it
also is allows you to do an incremental
move over time so if you separate out
your storage and compute you can do
something like move just a portion of
your data to a cloud you can experiment
on it you can move maybe just a few jobs
to Cloud Data proc see how it works
iterate rinse and repeat means you don't
have to do a wholesale lift and shift of
your cluster all at once because that's
really difficult to do it means that
people are trying to move a lot of
moving parts it's much easier to do it
incrementally when you also separate out
storage and compute it means that if you
put something some storage mechanism
like cloud storage you can use it with
other Google cloud products like Big
Brain you don't have to think about it
use ephemeral and long-lived clusters so
Cloud Data proc is best used ephemerally
because you can create clusters in under
90 seconds you can delete them at any
point we build by the second so from a
performance of economic standpoint
there's a lot of reasons to use
ephemeral clusters may not always be
able to because you have spark streaming
or honestly if you actually
want to run a persistent cluster some
people prefer to do that because the
predictability of their jobs is unknown
they have internal s LA's where seconds
matter whatever the reason is using a
mix of ephemeral and persistent clusters
works out for a lot of people right
sizing clusters so open source packages
are great because they allow you to do a
whole lot of really awesome things
they're really hard to use all on one
cluster because the way that you need to
configure the environment in terms of
the software in terms of the compute
resources maybe in terms of the location
for your data is just located in all
very so it depending on the type of
being that you want to do maybe the SLA
that you have maybe you don't care if
your Java MapReduce jobs take forever
maybe your biggest reason for moving a
little cloud to save money it's fine you
can create a small cluster have it
finish whenever you're ready you can
size it just to fit your preferences if
you have SPARC and you want it to run as
fast as possible you can resize that
cluster for that use case create and
delete clusters often the too long
didn't read version is if you don't have
a reason to keep your cluster just
delete it like don't please don't please
don't give us money to just run stuff
and just let it sit idle that's a bad
use of your money the jobs API so when
we meet a lot of customers in the movie
to Claudia to proc they're using things
like their own custom interfaces or a
web-based interface is to try and submit
five QL or submit and manage SPARC jobs
cloud data product has a jobs API that
sits on top of clusters it allows you to
submit and monitor jobs for some of the
more common job types we recommend that
people do it because you can do things
like stream output in real time the job
metadata will outlive the clusters so if
you delete the cluster all of the
information about your job will still be
there it also just makes your life
easier you don't have to think about web
UI is to try and submit jobs you don't
have to think about trying to create
user accounts for people to be able to
go create accounts and submit jobs on
clusters it just functionally makes your
life a lot easier
the common advice has worked out really
well but there's a set of new features
which are either in cloud data proc
today or are launching in the next few
weeks that will hopefully make moving to
plot a to proc just faster and easier
and more cost-effective and Karthik's
gonna run through some of those new
features with you he's gonna run through
some of them but not necessarily all of
them so if you are an avid release note
fan Claude data proc do weekly releases
as a teaser there are things that are
not covered here that are also coming
out in the next few weeks just to set
that up alrighty so I'm Karthik I am a
software engineer on the cloud data proc
team now I'm going to introduce you to
three new features so the first one is
custom images
so our base data pocket images come with
four components Hadoop spark hive and
pig but often times you want to run more
than that sometimes you can bring your
Java dependencies with your job but
often times you need to bring a lot more
so if you're installing servers or
you're compiling like Python
dependencies from source that can take a
lot longer so once your initialization
actions take more than just a few
minutes now if you create a large
cluster and your init actions I've even
heard a customer take an hour now you're
spending all that time just configuring
the cluster not actually processing the
data so the custom image you can build
an image and then give that to data proc
to use for your clusters and that really
helps you use ephemeral clusters so I'm
gonna go just go through a quick demo
here of creating a custom image
so first actually I have this bash
script called install kitchen sink so
I'm installing Jupiter our studio Apache
Zeppelin tensorflow and the HBase client
for a big table so just a bunch of
random things to take several minutes to
do as an init action normally
so since I don't want to waste your time
this would take a few minutes but I
already have a custom image we build so
I'm going to create a cluster based on
that
okay so as you can see the default here
is the base state of proc image and I'm
gonna go ahead and change that to a
custom image here
ten more projects and this is the one I
already pre-built so I'm just like that
go ahead and create it
all right so 452 anyone want to guess
how long this will take to create 60
second a little bit long in 60 seconds I
guess clustered in 90 seconds as this is
creating here you can see that there's a
custom image I can go ahead and click on
it and this image is in the GCE images
list and so this is managed by me and so
I can go ahead and delete it if I don't
want it anymore
all right put that one
I'm just gonna quickly show you here
just kidding hey the cluster is not
created yet but I just will just gonna
show you yes not is created
just check here kitchen sink too much
there you go alright so you can see that
this cluster already has Jupiter
installed because I created a cluster
with this custom image you know I now
have this like tensorflow hello world
here we could run so that's custom
images
all right so the second feature I want
to talk about here is data proper
workflows so with workflows you can
specify a cluster do you want jobs to
run on and also the jobs that you want
to run so this really gets to kind of
using ephemeral clusters previously you
would need to manage three different
operations you need to create a cluster
run jobs and then delete a cluster well
with workflows you can do all of that in
one step so really helping with the
automation there just kind of one deep
dive here with the workflow cluster you
can either specify a cluster that the
workflow will create just for those jobs
and teardown at the end or you can give
it a selector so if you want to manage
your own pool of clusters let's say you
have several clusters with the same
label then you can ask the workflow API
to run jobs on the least loaded cluster
with that label so I'll quickly show you
here
so this is a workflow temple I like to
use yellow files to specify my workflows
so this is a pretty common heavy
workload is called Terra sword so I have
Terrigen to generate a terabyte of data
terasort sorts the data and antara
validate validate since then it was
sorted correctly and you can see that
I'm using Pat's on Google Cloud storage
here for the data and then finally at
the bottom of this file in this case I
haven't managed cluster and the only
configuration out setting was the number
of workers so two is probably not enough
workers for this cluster so I'm just
going to go ahead and set it to 100 as
just as a guest so I can go ahead and
create this so I'm statue from file
cool so this workflow is going to create
a cluster run the three jobs one by one
and then finally delete the cluster at
the end so I don't need to manage those
steps independently so as you can see
here it's creating a cluster and and
again canceling is also simple so if I
don't want to actually wait for this to
finish you can go ahead and cancel it
so pretty neat help me get a lot of get
rid of a lot of bash grips actually
alright so this is the last feature I
wanted to talk about auto scaling so as
James was talking about before one of
the real benefits of cloud
infrastructure is that you can provision
and delete notes delete VMs on demand
but before with data proc you would
still have to notice that your cluster
was either underutilized or maybe you
had a lot of work queuing up and so you
have to manually resize the cluster but
now we have auto scaling so as James was
mentioning we do try to be a more knobby
feature that a lot of the rest of Google
cloud so with auto scaling you have
complete control we have a lot of these
do have defaults but you can specify
things like the min and Max workers for
primary substandard and preemptable
workers you can specify the cooldown
period so how often the auto scale
decides to scale now things like
graceful decommissioning and several
other properties yes it can cecilia the
question was can you scale down and the
answer is yes say it again
yes yes so I'll explain so a quick like
little deep dive here the way this works
it it's purely based on Hadoop yarn so
if you're unfamiliar yarn is the
scheduler of Hadoop so if I have you
know a hundred nodes and each has ten
gigabytes that I have you know a
thousand gigabytes of virtual like yarn
memory and my cluster so if I have
available memory from yarns perspective
that means that I'm actually over
provisioned I have too many nodes and I
can scale down and similarly if there's
a lot of work queued up in yarn that
doesn't have a space to be allocated i
appending memory and that means i need
to scale up the cluster so the auto
scaling policy is purely based on that
and so when we're talking about spark
you know spark as a job as executives
exit then you'll end up having available
memory and so we'll remove VMs to match
that workload so a quick demo here I
actually love using workflow templates
so I just modified my previous workflow
templates and added some auto scaling
properties so here I have a max of a
hundred standard workers and a hundred
preemptable workers so a total of a
maximum of 200 nodes and I asked it to
scale every ten minutes and just for fun
I decided to add in the custom image we
built earlier so similarly here we
instantiate from file
and of course this would take several
minutes to run actually like more like
an hour to run so we're not gonna wait
here for that I have run this before and
I'll show you the dashboard so this is
stackdriver alright so there are three
jobs you can kind of see them on the
left here the green right here is
pending memory so this is work heat up
and you can really think of this is the
amount of work remaining in the job so
this first stage here is Terrigen so you
can see that this is definitely smaller
than terasort so what happens here is
that initially it's very slow to
progress you can see that it's pretty
flat on the left but then you know if
you look over here the autoscaler scales
up which makes the work go down a lot
faster
similarly terasort is a lot bigger job
there's a lot more pending memory and
again the autoscaler scales up and so
again the slope is a lot steeper as the
work finishes faster and then finally
Terra Valley the cluster is about the
right size and so it's mostly constant
and then finally it's deleted so pretty
neat sorry
finding notes at the very end I was
wondering that too you can see that it
kind of goes up here as well
pending memory is still nonzero so there
is still actually work pending at the
very end the cluster just gets deleted
before the next cooldown period and so
that that's why it just drops off there
I have one more kind of neat demo so
this one was not done from a workflow
template which is actually why there's
like a few hours where the clusters are
sitting idle I actually forgot to delete
it so you use workflow templates
okay so this workload I was adding more
and more load up to kind of this point
here and then reduce the load throughout
so the chart sorry about that so this is
actually a bit misleading I am still
increasing the workload as it falls down
it's just that the autoscaler scaled up
as it detected more and more work so
right here the cluster is about the
right size and then when I add a ton
more work again the cluster scales up
and then finally as the work comes down
it scales back down yes so the question
was does auto scaling only work with
workflows the answer is no it's based on
data proc cluster properties so in
g-cloud if you ever use - - properties
you know often for like spark properties
it's the same thing and we will have
more time for Q&A at the end so don't
worry too much so a quick recap go back
to presenting here so we created a
custom image we wrote workflow templates
we enabled auto scaling and we saw the
cluster auto scale so again this really
gets to kind of awesome becoming more
and more managed service really helping
you automate your workflows so with that
I'll hand it back to James
so a few of those features are there
right now auto-scaling is coming in the
next two weeks the feature that I
alluded to earlier is also coming a few
weeks is selectable components where you
can pick and choose what you want
installed on your cluster which should
make it easier to customize the cluster
to you're lucky if you are curious and
want to get started more with Claude
data proc there's a few things that you
can check out there is a set of
migration guides which were expanding
over time migration guides are written
from the perspective of you already have
a monolithic or several monolithic
sparking to do pluster is you want to
move them to Google Cloud there is
information and the migration guides
right now about movie and your jobs and
moving your data we're expanding that
soon with a guide on how to think about
a security model in a cloud environment
versus a traditional on-premise
environment the Cloud Data proc Doc's
always have our newest features so in a
release new features release
documentation if you are really curious
to stay up to date with data proc
features the best thing to do is
actually just follow the RSS feed for
our release notes we do a weekly release
behind the scenes if you ever look at
the Claude data product images you'll
see that they're implemented every week
and the reason is is we're continually
building new images every week so it's a
really good way to stay up to date we
also have a stack overflow tag the team
actually looks at new questions that
come to the stack overflow tag you know
if you have a question you think others
might be interested in that question or
you think there might already be an
answer I strongly encourage you to use
that tag both just as a basis to see if
somebody already has asked a question or
just to share your question so others
might be able to find that information
as well
[Music]